hello there today we're looking at
corner net detecting objects as paired
key points by Hilah and Jia ding so on a
high level
this paper detects objects in images and
let's say this is an image and here's a
chair you know you have your chair and
the way you detect the chair for this
paper is going to be you detect the
bottom right and the top left corners of
the bounding box of the image
so rather than detecting the middle and
then specifying height and width like we
saw in the facebook DTR paper you detect
the two corners and this paper goes
through what they have to do to get this
to work including a new pooling method
called corner pooling so that's the
digits of the paper as always if you
like content like this consider
subscribing and sharing it out to other
people
that would be very helpful so a
commenter actually recommended this
paper to me after I made the video on
Facebook's Det our object detection
pipeline I said something like okay
since that paper always would detect the
middle of the object and the height and
width couldn't you make something that
else that detects the corners here and
the corner here and then that would
define a bounding box just as well and
in the comments and thank you very much
for that I someone made that pointed me
to this paper it's a bit older as you
can see but it's I still think it's it's
pretty cool so we've already seen the
the problem like the problem isn't hard
and it's it's detecting bounding boxes
in images and in this data set the
problems the difficult parts are that
you sometimes have multiple objects like
here if to humans they can be
overlapping they can be of different
sizes that could be like a third human
like small back here there can be other
objects you don't know how many there
are and so on so it is it is a fairly
complicated problem
but as I already said the way that
corner net here does this is by
predicting the locations of the top left
and bottom right corner there by
defining a bounding box and it does this
independently so there's one network
basically that does the top left and one
that does the bottom right and they
aren't then combined and at the end
they're sort of refined I think so the
architecture is pretty simple first you
put the image through a continent which
is like a feature extractor so this is
the basic part it was even the basic
part of Facebook's degr pipeline first
you have some sort of confident now they
in this case use in this hourglass or
architecture that described down down
here somewhere and this basically
compresses the image into a smaller
resolution so I would take that image
and compress it down to very small
resolution but many many channels so
it's sort of forced to learn a global
semantic representation and then it up
samples the image again and down samples
it again and it up samples it again
through so at each of these steps there
are many convolutional layers right here
and because that would lose you too much
space like local information there are
skip connections built in between pairs
of layers where information can travel
without computation basically so this is
a this is it's fairly standard or
architecture right here but then after
this hourglass CNN you get to these
prediction modules now let me switch
back to the top drawing ultimately what
you want as an output of these
prediction modules is two things so
first of all you want these heat maps
sorry but and these heat maps will
simply tell you where or the coroners
okay now the heat maps their dimensions
are the height of the image sorry the
height here age come on and the width of
the image and this here would be the
number of classes see okay so you have
one channel for each of the classes that
you predict and the the heat map will
basically be very high at the location
and channel where there is a corner of
that so you see you have one heat map
for the top left corners and one heat
map for the bottom right corners and
then also what you want to predict are
these embeddings now simply because you
have you know I said there can be
multiple instances of the same class in
the in the same image so now you have in
this case particularly
you were gonna if even if you predict
absolutely correctly you predict two top
left corners and two bottom right
corners now this isn't particularly hard
because there's only one configuration
that can possibly be but there could be
situations where there are multiple and
that's why you need to somehow match
these corners you have to match you have
to know which one's of those are the
same objects and they do this by a
second output in their heads called this
embeddings these embeddings there are
simply vectors and the only thing that
they're asked to do is they're asked to
have a large inner product
whenever they belong to the same object
and they are asked to have a small inner
product of sorry when they're when they
belong to the different two different
objects so this orange thing here would
have a large inner product with this
green bottom right corner embedding okay
so you train these embeddings they don't
need to mean anything you simply train
them to predict the same thing for the
same objects and different things for
different objects so after that when you
match the corners you can simply go over
you can say oh this which one of these
two right here has the larger inner
product or you
do like some Hungarian matching and
maximize the total inner product or
something like this this was quite
surprising to me that it works but it's
based on a line of research that is
already has already established that
this can work because ultimately these
things these two pipelines do not really
communicate right so I'm going to guess
what they learn is sort of a sort of a
descriptor of the actual object that's
there because if both describe the
objects that that's there with their
embeddings they're embeddings are gonna
have a large inner product and if they
describe different objects then they're
embeddings are not going to match right
so even though you train that this
objective I still think that these
embeddings would pick up something about
the object something about the visual
characteristics of the objects will be
very interesting to see whether someone
could actually parse out what they what
they do because it's almost impossible
otherwise for these things to be learn
about alright so that's the that's the
goal right here you want to get these
heat maps in these embeddings and the
way you do it is fairly easy
architectural II you have these two
prediction modules one for top left and
one for bottom right and each of them
have three outputs the heat maps the
embeddings and here the offsets are
simply a way for you to deal with the
fact that you down sample and by down
sampling you have to round certain
pixels to certain locations and then the
offsets they they compensate for this
but I don't want to focus on these right
now so you simply have these two outputs
right here now we'll look at corner
pooling in a second but how do you train
this so you can now say okay if I have a
picture like this there there is exactly
two locations in the class human where
the the top left corner is correct
and that's right here and that's right
here okay so two locations so I feel I
make my matrix my target matrix with a
one here and the one here and zeros
everywhere else
all right zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero and I train my network to give me
this particular thing as an output for
this heat for this heat map in the
channel human this this might work but
it is more profitable let's say if you
allow for some slack so what they say is
you know since if if I'm anywhere within
this orange circle right here with my
prediction my resulting bounding box is
still going to overlap fairly well with
the ground truth bounding box and the
accuracy measures for these things I
think are based on how much you overlap
with the ground truth bounding boxes so
what they do basically is they they give
they put a 1 in the spot where the
actual corner is and then they put like
a 0.9 around it 0.9 0.9 and so on and
they kind of flatten out so this is sort
of a Gaussian right here in multiple
dimensions if that drawing makes any
sense and they say well you the closer
you are basically the more reward you
get so you train it to predict in in
this general location now of course the
size exact size of this Gaussian has to
be dependent on the actual size of the
box itself and they have they they
regard that and say exactly how they
calculate these gaussians but for the
understanding is just important that
they do give some slack here in how they
compute the loss with respect to the
heat map now the loss with respect to
the to the embeddings is pretty simple
pretty straightforward so remember these
embeddings you
to embeddings for you have the top-left
imbedding that's the etk the top and the
top corner embedding and you have the
bottom right embedding and what you want
is for them to be close together when
they describe the same object right so
this is this push and pull losses so in
the pull loss what you want to do is you
want to minimize the distances of these
two things to this thing right here and
this thing is simply so EK is simply the
the mean so it's e TK + eb k divided by
2 that's simply if your top left corner
is here and your bottom right corner is
here and they have embeddings this one
has this embedding and this one has that
embedding then the mean of the two
embeddings which i guess is whatever
this right here yeah that's about the
mean it so the location is not important
actually so it's about the embedding
vectors it's not about where the corners
are the two embedding vectors must be
close together and you model that not
directly by making them close to each
other but by making both close to their
mean and that probably saves you some
backpropagation troubles where you if
you if you have two moving parts in a
loss function and you optimize both then
you tend to so you have two things you
want to bring them closer together they
might tend to overshoot or something
like this okay so this brings those two
closer together and in the push loss
what you want to do is you want to
simply make the mean between the two
remember this is this is the mean this
is the mean embedding of this object far
away from the mean embedding of any
other object in the picture okay so this
M here is a is a margin loss which means
that you you cap it at some point so the
if they're close together you if two
different if
weddings of two different objects are
close together you can see here this
quantity will be small and therefore it
will lead to this Delta you give a loss
of 1 the Delta here is 1 in this case
but as they get further apart you're
more and more happy and you reduce your
loss until you don't give you so you
don't give any any bonus for them being
super far apart you don't simply don't
want them to be closer together than 1
all right
in their case I think they have a the
dimension of these vectors is actually 1
which basically means they just output a
single number which I find astonishing
that that that works yes they use
embeddings of one dimension so they can
just use numbers astonishing that it
works but ok so that's how you train the
the embedding output embeddings close
together of the same objects of the two
corners and embeddings far apart for
different objects alright so we can now
predict where the corners are and we can
match them now one center part of this
is the corner pooling and why is the
corner pooling necessary so what's the
problem with this sort of approach the
problem and they have an example right
here the problem when you want to
predict a corner of an object is that in
a CNN what CNN can is good at is like
local neighborhood information right so
if you have to predict let's go for the
moon actually here let's predict the
location of the moon if I have to
predict the location of the moon and I'm
a CNN and I have this receptive field
I'm like oh yes it's like in here and
then I have this receptive field and I'm
like yes it's in here and then i zoom in
on the corner not on the moon itself but
on the corner where I need to predict
right at some point I like I'm sort of
I'm like wait wait where is it because
in this particular fee
receptive field of that this resolution
I have I have no clue if the moon is
closed right so at the location where
the actual bounding box is I have no
local information of the object because
usually objects are not squares they're
sort of round like the moon or like here
the plane these corners they have no
local information about where the plane
is and corner pooling is a method to
propagate that information along the
axis so what corner in corner pooling
what you would allow the location here
in the CNN to do is to not only look at
its itself so its own location but
actually to extend its field of view
over to the right and down to the bottom
its asks you predict a top left corner
so what you do is you max pool
everything from here to this corner
detector so the corner detector will
basically be able to detect whenever in
either this band right here so whenever
in this band right here there is the top
at the top of an object like the top of
the moon here this corner detector can
say ah that's probably the right height
right here for a corner and it combines
this with the information of this this
side here where it also says oh there is
the side of the moon that's probably the
correct you know up down so there's
probably a corner right here okay where
as a like a location right here which
would get the same signal from the right
or like almost the same signal plus this
signal right here but in essence it
would also detect the top of the moon
but it would not get the same signal
from down here and therefore it says uh
even though to the right I see some the
top of an object I don't see the left of
an object to my bottom so I'm not going
to period
predict a corner right
all right so this corner pooling goes
for the top left and of course
equivalently goes for the bottom right
that can always max pools to up and to
the left of itself and that's exactly
what you see here so in this corner
pooling what you can do is you can
propagate signal to the left and to up
and then you add the two informations
and that will give you your output
feature and you can calculate this
actually fairly efficiently by doing
like like a you do a cumulative sum you
do like a cumulative maximum across the
different axes and then you simply add
two arrays and that's it
so you simply put the corner pooling
before you predict the these different
outputs right here the heat maps and the
embeddings which means that this
hourglass network is not affected by
this just the predictors of heat maps
and embeddings they then get the
information from this hourglass Network
into these into these directions okay I
think that's a pretty pretty neat method
of solving this and here they show how
you can calculate this and then the
corner polling is right here they do add
a skip connection here because sometimes
if you just aggregate this information
you might you might actually get
confused because so the trouble of
course comes when there are multiple
like different objects that have you
know the same top and then there is also
person right here that so it gets like a
signal it gets another signal that there
is the left side of a person right here
or maybe you know not like this so it
will it will predict like a corner maybe
here where there is none sorry it's it's
sometimes it is important to have local
information still and that's exactly
what this skip connection is supposed to
address I guess the situation up here
would be
resolved by the different embeddings but
still so you have that you add and you
put another bunch of convolutional
layers on top of that and then you'll
get your predictions and that's it you
mix all the losses so there is a
detection loss from the embeddings
there's sorry from the heat maps there
is the pull and push losses for the
embeddings and there's this offset loss
that you train to compensate for the
down the down sampling errors and that's
it and they oblate the various things
here basically they show that they're
better than other one shot or one stage
predictors is so apparently there's one
stage predictors where you have a single
pass through a neural network and
there's two stage predictors where we
have multiple or two passes through
different neural networks and they
compete in the in the one one stage
neural network category if so to say and
they show that they get significant
improvements with and do to this corner
pooling which is pretty cool to see
because it makes sense it sort of makes
sense how you would like to think about
it like this and to see that it helps is
pretty neat yeah they also investigate
how large they have to make these these
gaussians and so on and there are some
qualitative examples you can see that
without the corner pooling what you'll
get is it so the top here and the left
and the right are correct are detected
correctly but you can see that probably
the network thinks that there is an
extension of the object right here and
therefore doesn't do doesn't do a good
job because this this position right
here it has no access to so sort of it
has to use like a long-range access it
can't it can't really look in detail at
the features here
here so when it scans up and down this
side where the bottom corner where the
bottom break is it can it can only look
at very coarse features because it has
to basically transmit information in the
CNN of a higher layer and the higher
layer has a higher receptive field which
means it has a lower resolution so we
can't really go and look very in very
detailed fashion at this border right
here so it misses it okay the same right
here as you can see so there are a
number of failure cases that they can
now solve using this method compared to
if they didn't use the corner pooling
they show some also some times where
their method fails for example here
it matches the top bot top left and
bottom right corners of two different
objects because they they're embeddings
were close enough and yeah that's what
I'm saying
I'm I'm wondering what these embeddings
actually learn because they they are
generated independently so not entirely
sure it's also not exactly what I had in
mind when I formulated this idea in the
last video but I'm actually not sure
what I had in mind myself to be honest
but in my mind it seemed to be like you
should be able to train a network if
there is an object right here you could
train a network to predict for any given
location let's say how many pixels to
its bottom right or maybe you want to
normalize by the area that's there or
part of a particular object and then you
could use you could predict each pixel
and use like the differences between the
differences between the points as as
scores for bounding boxes I don't know
if you see what I mean
you could basically tell the but you
have you have one network predict
everything to the to the bottom right
and then you'd use the differences and
the
transformers would be very good at that
because they can sort of have this
attention between each pairs of points
and so on I'm not entirely sure but this
might just be crap yeah here's some more
examples this appears to work really
nicely but of course in the qualitative
qualitative examples it always works
nicely but they also demonstrate it
alright I found this paper all in all
pretty cool pretty neat it's it's a
simple idea it's executed well I don't
have the feeling that there are like too
many tricks in here and they show really
that the improvement seems to be due to
their their corner pooling method and
that's pretty neat so if you like this
paper make sure to check it out and I'll
see you next time bye bye